welcome back to new rock stars the
trailer for spider-man no way home blows
open the spider-verse with reveals or at
least hints toward at least five
villains from past franchises doc alfred
molina green goblin norman osborne
electro jamie foxx the lizard re-siphons
and sandman thomas satan church
scraping the bottom of the barrel there
but there are
no offense those guys are great but uh
there are rumors that there is a sixth
villain rounding out this sinister six
lineup how the hell is there room for
anyone else in this movie
and is the sixth villain truly
ungrateful fans who will somehow find a
way to put dirt in our eye this is rogue
theory the show where we pitch the
wildest theories for the nerdy titles we
love i'm eric voss going rogue with me
in this week of weeks is mastertainment
empty
what's going on guys it's spiderman week
we made it we are
here we are blessed with the trailer
also here with us is host of the film
philosophers podcast eddie villarrueva
can i just say it's about damn time
because i didn't think we were ever
going to get this trailer and now that
it's here i'm still not even sure we saw
it i feel like it's still the simulation
so i i don't know i don't know it was
all dreaming uh and swinging in from her
own dimension it's jessica clement hey
i'm proud to say i didn't watch the leak
video because i'm a true fan oh my god
it's the canister for the computer and i
always accidentally get hired
accidentally just accidentally
you guys don't worry about anything
don't worry about anything just just
don't look at me don't look at him no
it's impossible
well um the no way home trailer teased
five iconic spider-verse villains stock
green goblin electro sand man the lizard
but rumor has it there is a sixth hiding
in the shadows maybe even hiding in
plain sight so who do we think this
villain is the trailer gives us lots of
clues that maybe doctor strange might
have a bit more of an antagonistic
relationship that with peter parker than
we thought also some clues pointing to
mephisto
uh and there's plenty of other
spider-verse villains left over that we
don't really know yet like michael
keaton is a vulture uh scorpion uh is
mysterio still alive venom and carnage
are they gonna
whip into all this maybe an alternate
peter parker uh let's go through all
these options let's start with doctor
strange do we think doctor strange is
going to be peter parker's enemy
ah yes okay
okay dude i've been watching this
trailer over and over again and i've
been and the hardest things about these
trailers are piecing together their
outfits and being like he's not wearing
this in this scene he's not wearing this
in this scene there has to be a
different person also like he's not he
didn't have this this broke in the later
movie blah blah blah x infinity so i
would love this is also rogue theory so
why not go rogue i would love for this
strange that performs the spell to
actually be a variant of king the
conqueror now i know like cause he was
saying that he was just like oh a bunch
of me's are coming a bunch of me that
are really smart a bunch of sorcerers
are really evil and instead of being the
evil sorcerer but i would love it to
just be like a variant of kang just
popping in there and that could be the
sixth one i think it would be just so
grounded for like after loki but i don't
know how serious it could possibly be i
don't know if like because i was also
like trying to figure out where the
timeline matched with all of this and it
seems like it's so far
that it could be true i don't know i
just wanted to be king i just wanted to
be a variant of king so we stay on board
you know now that we have things like
variants in the universe it's just so
hard to pin anything down it's kind of
like when squirrels got introduced like
far from home ended with nick fury
turning back into a scroll so
anybody could be a variant anybody could
be a scroll that deception makes it
really fun to theorize about
for me when it comes to like doctor
strange it's hard for me to imagine him
being a disguise for someone like kang
or mephisto but i could see him very
likely having some kind of allegiance or
loyalty or partnership with one another
yeah like he knows about kang or he
knows
so and the reason he's weird in this
trailer is that he's like uh either
trying to avoid them or try to serve
them unwittingly you know
i'm jumping on that board because that
would make more sense also strange made
a bargain with a counter i think
with that
bargain
he likes a good deal
who doesn't like a good deal
i think i think mt hit on something
though too as well because i think one
of the biggest things that we
as the mcu fans have kind of pulled away
from are the events that happened in the
first doctor strange movie and i i am a
huge fan of chewito legio4 and i
honestly feel like mordo has a role
behind this like i feel like if he is
either using some kind of incantation
maybe to disguise himself as strange or
even to have a sway over strange with
you know the the efforts be with
dormammo behind him you know because one
of the unique things about the the
trailer and mind you just like jess i've
been re-watching this thing like crazy
one of the unique things that i saw at
the very beginning was you know when
he's looking at those little uh witch
figurines and if you look at the one
that he's actually looking at he
actually has a goatee and he has teeth
and it's like oh my god you're seriously
looking at something something that's
been manipulated to get his attention so
i feel like i don't think that doctor
strange is trying to to lead him to
himself but i think it's someone else
who's trying to lead him to doctor
strange because there's already a hold
on doctor strange in some way or some
form
but i feel like dormammu and mordo
have kind of a play in this as well
because i i feel like there's still some
kind of saltiness there's got to be some
kind of saltiness from dormammu from at
the end of doctor strange so uh yeah i
think if doctor strange has some kind of
hold over him um like why would he
engage peter parker in this spell do we
think doctor strange planned on that
spell
going awry or is that genuinely
something that happened outside of his
control and now he's panicked oh i i
just think it's a spell that just went
totally wrong i think that he tried to
do it and he was like yo i i saved the
universe like a zillion times what i do
i freaking beat their mama i'd be thanos
i'll i beat death all day like this no
one can beat me because i'm the smartest
dude in the multiverse and so he does it
and things go wrong and so yeah i think
it's just a weird accident that's why i
was thinking it had to be like a variant
of him because i was also like what if
this variant isn't as
like
as well to do as our doctor strange he's
just like slightly a little bit under
and so i was like what if he just
completely messed up on the spell on
purpose and was like yeah i don't care
i don't i really don't care see i think
doctor strange could be an antagonistic
force to peter parker in this movie um
but i don't think we would consider him
the sixth villain because in my mind the
only way that works is if doctor strange
is the only villain and the other
sinister six characters we're seeing are
actually neutral characters or people
caught up in in a mess and then they
don't really know how they tie into the
broader plot and it's like doctor
strange pulling all the strings so i
wouldn't consider doctor strange the
sixth villain he would just be like the
twist kang behind it all or whatever you
would would you consider the the coming
together of the sinister six or sinister
seven however many there may actually be
that haven't been told do you think
that's something that's going to be
preconceived prior to the events of
whatever doctor strange and spider-man
do or it's going to occur during the
film that's kind of a question right
like how planned was this multiverse
collision i mean if you consider someone
like kang or mephisto being behind this
uh ultimately planned everything's going
according to plan but if you consider it
like an accident then then eddie's other
alternative is probably true that they
just meet each other and they're like
hey you're from another universe too
you're from another universe hey there's
like six of us you get your ass by
spider-man i get my ass by spider-man
we have so much in common oh my god i
got my whooped in my eyes
honestly and that's it's like imagine a
jail cell where they all got out at the
same time it's like we're going
b-lining for spider-man so why not work
together just like immediately when you
come out of that hole to just go find
the first man in a spider suit
i think it's the latter i think like
these characters are going to be trapped
in a kind of prison i honestly think
that cube is a pocket prison it's a
ghostbuster trap and they all share it
together and it's gonna be like usual
suspects they're all in confinement and
they're like hey let's plan a new let's
plan a new gig a new heist together and
it's like the cops created this scenario
by introducing these criminals together
um but in the usual suspects there was a
kaiser soze at the end of the day so uh
my like we should talk about mephisto
there either already is a video on the
channel or there will be a video soon
with my whole theory on mephisto but
like yeah there are some signs pointing
to like doctor strange being unusual
that devil in disguise sign then one
more day comic that seems to be based on
um but i just my gut tells me that we're
not going to see a devil smiling at
someone through a mirror unless that
devil is william defoe doing his bit
like like i don't think this is going to
be in this movie but i think as always
characters could secretly be uh
manipulated by mephisto like i think we
may see like a post-credit scene where
doctor strange just hears a voice from
the shadows and that's what's freaking
him out and what causing them to make
these irrational choices but what do you
guys think about mephisto i
sorry just quick and easy i don't think
he's gonna show up in this but i do
think they're definitely teeing up if
they want to down the line to literally
slide him in we there's so many places
to put him and also they're just like
teasing us by putting like so much stuff
in yeah i think so
they're just doing that because they're
tired of everybody they're tired of just
being like hurt
yeah he's tired of he's they're tired of
boss cover your ears they're tired of
eric boss so
[Laughter]
they're they're tired of him them a
pistol and everyone riding that train
but no i don't think he's gonna show up
in this and they're like is my fist on
even on the board hold on
every scene and there's so many times
i've watched so many different videos of
people being like let's zoom in like
enhance enhance to find an m like a red
m or something and i'm like no you know
what i'm not and that's the truth okay
people think those are new rock stars
videos we didn't do that crazy of
these are these tick tockers who steal
our and then put that incredible
syndrome song over it
the amount of times that i'm like
reading just like people friends talking
about it on discord and they're like yo
i wonder what eric boss is gonna say and
i'm like how does everybody just like
the boss didn't come up with this it
wasn't
i never said the butterflies were
mephisto i never said the crane was
mephisto but everyone thinks i said
everything i mean
any publicity is good publicity but
still no exactly
not when it comes to the death jessica
how dare you
but i think um
mephisto ultimately is kind of maybe too
big of a villain to be considered the
sixth of of you know six villains like
he would overshadow the others with his
cosmic
powers
so he doesn't need the others at all he
could just do it himself he's a cosmic
villain yeah he's the justin timberlake
of that super secret boycott there you
go
i'm going solo i don't need y'all yeah
um one day mapista will apologize for um
making a single about brittany and then
uh his britney is trapped in the
conservative
exactly um but let's talk about some
lower tier options who could be uh part
of a sinister six lineup like vulture or
scorpion are you guys thinking we might
see them again yes i think because um my
guess for the sixth uh member of the
sinister six is prowler because we had
donald glover
the first movie and they set him up to
be prowler and we haven't seen that yet
and since it's the third movie in this
trilogy and obviously they're most
likely going to make another spider-man
trilogy it's probably going to be a
spider-verse trilogy fingers crossed um
but you know we haven't seen that
actually develop so we could see a
either you know donald clover variant
from our reality or seeing a variant
from another reality and popping up and
being like yo i got beef with you peter
parker or maybe he could be seeing miles
morales because like in the um in the
trailer we see that um peter parker is
wearing the uh the rainy spider-man get
up and so what if all of the villains
are seeing their version of peter parker
and like maybe prowler sees miles
morales because like that's his
spider-man like different version of
spider-man i mean like they see their
spiderman just like yeah
like i don't know like i'm just gonna
fight we all have personal beef with
like this spider avatar i don't know i
would love nothing more than for all of
the villains to be fighting them prowl
are just like
yeah i should be fighting too and jump
into it
because that's the only way we could let
him come in but yeah that seems like a
good idea i like that idea a lot um and
uh donald glover was an interesting
thing they set up in uh homecoming and i
i'd love to see him show back up uh as
part of this team i think would be a
really fun i guess call back if you will
to the
mysterious final member
would be i mean and this would be pretty
interesting especially with the um
you know coming back of vincent
d'onofrio as kingpin
oh sure you know having the head if you
will someone who has the means to make
these types of things feasible in terms
of getting people together
um that would be really great especially
when we're trying to make that bridge
now from the
tv series you know version of marvel
into the marvel cinematic universe
that'd be a great bridge to use to
create that from that aspect yeah what
an interesting idea and that could be
the way we get charlie cox daredevil in
this too because i don't want if we
hopefully do get charlie cox in the mcu
i don't want him to be the only person
to come from that side of the netflix
universe i mean d'onofrio did such a
great job with wilson fisk and i'd love
to see him be the kingpin of the mcu and
he wants to do it so badly so like give
it to him that's fantastic um now i
would imagine sony's hope for the sixth
member of the team would be like venom
or carnage do you guys think they could
show up one of them could show up in
this movie i think they're gonna be the
stinger at the end i think i think
that'd be so cool too if they if that's
how they're like gonna bring or not how
they're gonna bring them in but i want
them to show up so bad in this how are
you going to bring in every part every
villain but you're not going to bring in
any of those pieces like i just want it
so bad but i and i still hold on to the
fact that i think it will be like a
stinger at the very end of the movie
that will see venom or carnage
oh yeah i think that the symbiote is
definitely going to make some type of
appearance in this movie because this is
a multiverse film and the symbiotes are
you know a primordial you know ooze from
the beginning of time so like yeah it
just seems like if there there is a link
that you could you know easily introduce
the symbiotes and we have the venom
universe and like sony's doing their own
thing with their own sony spider-man
characters that i'm sure that they want
to link up in some way so there's gonna
be some type of whether it's like very
very loose link to the venom universe
that's going to introduce the symbiotes
yeah i think that'd be really fun uh now
i have to address this do you think
mysterio could still be alive and
gyllenhaal could absolutely
that man is a snakey i do do not
trust quentin beck for one second
because
freaking nick fury i said this all the
time nick fury faked his death in winter
soldier with that uh pill that he took
whatever the hell so if you freaking
beck was had all this starks people and
all these people like that hated tony
hanging out with him he could have
easily gotten that thing that to
simulate his death so he's just walking
away scot-free yeah i don't think he's
gone at all especially with so much more
uh possibilities with his character in
that universe and and if sony decides to
bring him back and make him a much
bigger part as the future continues for
whatever they have in store for
spider-man i have no doubt that's a card
that they're really holding close to
their chest and they're you know really
hoping to play that right at the exact
perfect time
um now the last option i want to ask you
guys about do you think the sixth member
of the team could be an alternate peter
parker like emo peter parker
black suit venom symbiote peter parker
could be the sixth member of the team
it's possible but i i don't really see
that being something because they're
also going to be doing something like
that within to the spider verse where
they're going to be incorporating many
more different uh very variants now we
can say it of spider-man in that realm
um i don't know if they'd play the the
the
alternate universe spider-man version in
this one
yeah it'd be an interesting i wanted to
bring it up but the alliances and uh
alignments are a bit hard to see in that
scenario like wood really even black
suit uh toby maguire peter parker want
to align himself with with doc ock and
and uh green goblin
like i don't know if he's he was that
kind of evil you know yeah uh it would
have to be a very specific set of
circumstances that would make him want
to join forces with them
possible just yeah but like i think that
though the evil peter parker thing is
highly probable because the spider-verse
comics i believe in if i'm wrong just
you could edit this out they came from
the shattered dimensions video game
where at the end of that it's revealed
that peter parker is the villain behind
the whole multiverse shenanigans so
you know there is some type of precedent
for it because those comics would not
have existed without that video game oh
there's precedence for everything
they're really there's probably peter
parker's
in the past as well you need to throw a
rock and you have precedence there it is
just
it didn't happen but if they were to
make a secret wars
in the mcu
i would rather an evil peter parker come
in then to fight peter parker then i
feel like this movie already has so much
going on to make him like look in a
mirror and fight himself is like another
thing
when he's already fighting like seven
different enemies from different
timelines so i don't think so but i
would love to see him go against himself
eventually to be like who would win
peter or
peter one last thought what do you guys
think about
craven
being that
aaron taylor johnson yeah totally forget
about them taylor jones don't sleep on
crazy that is you know what that is
highly probable there because like that
would be a great little stinger for like
the next trailer because it's like what
why are we saying quicksilver why is he
here and people are gonna be like oh my
god variance and loki yeah that's 100 a
really good one that's fantastic um
i would like to see craven i love him
more i love reading him with the
sinister six
but i which is sad which is really sad
to say and honestly please edit this out
uh i want to see the lizard because he
didn't have really a good job
i was really i was a huge fan and i was
like a lizard yeah it's already there oh
wait is he in it yeah he's in the
trailer yeah wait you're in
know why i was thinking chameleon and
well then i'm not paying attention to
the trailer close enough you got to
watch my breakdown
i thought she said chameleon for some
reason no i said lizard lizard's one of
the
some people thought it was venom but
he's when peter's in a like a dungeon
that i think is that when he yells
uh no it's uh peter he's like and he
turns around
and then i kept freezing it and it's too
dark on my damn
you got to break it so i was i kept i
swear to god i kept pausing it because i
could be like this is someone i edit
this out but i was like this is someone
who's like
hard to figure it out should i watch the
breakdown that's not me that's not me
well we covered some great options here
um i'm going to award jessica you one
point for um for this kang idea i think
strange might have had some connection
with kang uh or either wittingly or
unwittingly i think kang knew who
strange was strange might know who kang
was i'm giving you a point for that uh
mt i love this idea of prowler uh and i
i honestly forget about prowler but in
spider-man homecoming on donald glover's
rap sheet they list the name prowler so
like he is established as prowler of the
mcu and uh i think he's long overdue for
a return yeah eddie i'm gonna give you a
point for kingpin um i think he is a
classic spider-man villain i think they
already have a great actor for the part
and this way they could get both charlie
cox and d'onofrio in there i'm gonna
give you a second point for craven uh
because craven we know is coming soon as
he's got his own sony movie coming up i
feel like this is going to be a place
they'd want to introduce him all right
great job everybody we want to talk more
about the spider-man no way home trailer
some thoughts about who left the ac
running all night in the sanctum
sanctorum but first
our merch partners at epic hero just
released a really cool no way home
inspired shirt tales from the multiverse
number one there's going to be other
shirts in this series and they're going
to be limited edition so get on it they
also have this what if inspired shirt
and there's like loki and suicide squad
inspired shirts and merch all kinds of
cool nerdy gear so show your support for
new rockstars and get yourself some
great nerdy gear at
newrockstarsmerch.com we want to thank
mint mobile for sponsoring this episode
after years of fine print contracts and
getting ripped off by big wireless
providers we have learned that there's
always a catch so when we heard that
mint mobile offers premium wireless
service starting at just 15 bucks a
month we wondered what the catch could
be well the catches there isn't one
they're the first company to sell
wireless service online only they cut
out the overhead costs and pass on those
sweet savings directly to you and the
rockstars philip actually switched to
mit mobile he loves it he got to keep
his phone and his number and he's saving
a bunch of money for people looking for
extra savings mint mobile offers premium
wireless for just 15 bucks a month all
plans come with unlimited talk and text
plus high speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5g network and if
you're not 100 satisfied mint mobile has
you covered with their seven day money
back guarantee switch to mint mobile and
get premium wireless service starting at
just 15 bucks a month to get your new
wireless plan for just 15 bucks a month
and to get the plan shipped to your door
for free go to mintmobile.com rogue
theory that's mint mobile dot com slash
rogue theory cut your wireless bill to
just 15 bucks a month at midmobile.com
rogue theory we also want to thank
hawthorne for sponsoring this episode
this summer it's been easier than ever
to drop our personal care routines right
but with your personalized grooming kit
from hawthorne it's easy to stay on
track hawthorne is a premium grooming
brand that tailors your personal care
routine to your unique profile first you
take their quiz they ask me questions
about my skin type and how often i shave
it was really easy it only took a few
minutes at the end i got an essentials
bundle with the products tailored to my
body type and lifestyle i got deodorant
face wash shampoo and other products
that are specifically selected for me
they all smell great and i feel great
when i use them hawthorne takes the risk
out of shopping for personal care by
giving you free shipping on your order
and returns with their subscription
options personalized to your usage
hawthorne makes sure you never run out
of your essentials life is complicated
hawthorne keeps it simple with a short
studyback quiz that matches you with
your perfect grooming kit looking your
best has never been easier so take
hawthorne's quiz today and get started
on your personalized self-care routine
by going to hawthorne.co
and use promo code rogue to get 10 off
your first purchase that's
h-a-w-t-h-o-r-n-e dot c-o promo code
rogue hawthorne.co promo code rogue and
we want to thank simply safe for
sponsoring this episode when simply safe
home security's founders chad and
eleanor laurens designed their first
security system in their kitchen they
did it for a very personal reason their
friends had just had their home broken
into they were struggling to find a
security system that was simple to set
up and would make them feel safe again
editor john loves his simply safe system
and he got it because his mom loves hers
they are a multi-generational simply
safe family
making people feel safe is what simply
safe has been doing ever since that
moment 15 years ago a passion to protect
people not only drives every engineering
detail in its products but it motivates
every interaction with its customers
simply safe makes it so easy it takes
about two minutes to customize the
system on their website simplysafe.com
rogue simply safe has trained security
experts ready whenever you need them
whether that's during a fire a burglary
a medical emergency or even just when
you're setting up the system there's
always someone there who has your back
to keep you safe as our listener you can
save 20 off your simply safe security
system and get your first month for free
when you sign up for interactive
monitoring service just visit
simplisafe.com rogue to customize your
system and start protecting your home
and family that's simply safe dot com
slash rogue all right everybody what
happened to the sanctum sanctorum why is
it frozen and covered in ice uh dr
strange seems unable to use his magic to
thaw it out he's resorted to covering
himself up in layers wong's getting the
f out of there packed his luggage headed
back to the sanctum sanctorum it looks
like probably soon gonna be fighting
with abomination and a warmer climate uh
so
what is going on here why is it frozen
oh my god i truly think that just one of
the
the doors that open to different like
geographical places literally just
erupted only because in the trailer it
does have that man just
like sweeping up this guy so i don't
think it's that big of a thing like an
intern yeah
it's
it's a wizard and training that'd be
hilarious if wong had his own servant
because he's like
it truly i feel like it was so minor to
everyone around them because they were
just like yeah we just put on jackets uh
wong's getting the hell out of here this
guy's sweeping up the snow he's
shoveling and
peter came in and his normal outdoor
clothes so it's just like
it's only inside this bubble and and the
unique thing about that whole scene is
that
dr strange is wearing his his cloak and
everything but he's got like
like regular new york winter clothes
under home winter clothes underneath
it's like a sweat like a college
sweatshirt and sweatpants and everything
so
mind you this might not be the most
popular idea but i mean
going back this was kind of a secondary
idea to what we were talking about
earlier with doctor strange but
what if doctor strange is going through
a mid-life crisis like like the
possibility of the fact that he
died and came back and now before he was
kind of an arrogant person and now he's
like you know i'm gonna i'm gonna
cherish like the whole like doc uh mr
scrooge kind of thing you know christmas
carol you know and and i'm gonna do
these things i'm gonna you know oh peter
we did this together so why not throw
this together out there and like kind of
like part of like you know the
weather changes wanting to do things
differently shake things up instead of
it always being dark and gloomy now it's
like a winter wonderland inside the
sanctum sanctorum um i was just i was
thinking i'm like man what if he's just
going through it like what if he's just
going first
he's just trying to figure out life
maybe where are you i just want to make
a snowball man like thanos stressed me
out i just want to make a snowman
snowball
where are they in the timeline if far
from home
is way after the so it's far from and
then this so it's like what was he doing
during far from home do we know
exactly
like that's
yes but my answer was yeah excuse me
excuse me
yeah i think mt is uh affirming your
curiosity and saying that we all uh are
confused by this okay okay doctor
strange was just kicking it in the
sanctum sanctorum i think that's all we
know
i don't know when you're roasting me or
when you guys are being serious oh no
i agree i don't know
i've killed them all i've made ten olafs
and i've killed them all i'm done yeah
so he's just chilling okay
so he's just just died because frozen
yeah this movie is set after far from
home it's right after far from home and
it's like summertime going into fall
right because
new york uh at the end of far from home
seemed to be in the middle of the summer
but now uh these shots look like fall
leaves are taking over the nearby parks
well because you got halloween
decorations
yeah oh so it's halloween yeah so some
time will have passed like peter gets
arrested and then he starts to try to
adjust to the new normal of being a
pariah and you know about two months of
that and then he's like you know what
that halloween direction looks like
doctor strange i remember now that i
have a friend named
strange is probably weird not to say
that his mental health isn't important
but why there's something up with him
yeah i mean we don't know what the
status of i mean talking about you know
rogue theory relationship theory uh you
know we don't know what was going on
with him and rachel mcadams character
during that time before you know that
point
the big blip so i mean maybe he's also
like in his fields you know
breaking out the boom box and like just
wanting to just
i mean
who knows
that's why i'm asking you guys
wait we don't know why are you asking
huh
i actually i do i'm the one that leaked
the trailer
[Laughter]
whoever has the balls to leak that
trailer is the
i don't know i can i i would get shot so
i would get shot someone might be
getting shot as we speak yeah like it
still could happen um no i think i think
that a good chance of why
the sanctum could be frozen could be
linked to
i sort of have two guesses um one could
be completely due to where the hell
doctor strange was and far from home
like that could just be their way of
just like they're coming back it's like
oh man we just went on this weird frozen
adventure we just fought a yeti it was
really crazy man oh yeah what what
happened mysterio who uh what what what
was going on
so it could be that or it could be the
sanctum is responding to whatever the
hell mordo is doing as a response to you
know no more like too many wizards and
it's just like oh no the magic in the
world it's going cold i'm getting cold i
can't heat myself up it all goes back to
frozen
you know this ties back to frozen so
it's sort of reflecting the health of
like the magic in the marvel universe
that makes sense that's the idea idea i
like it's like uh narnia rules like when
the white witch takes over tilda swinton
in a different cinematic universe uh
everything was frozen it was a
representing factor of the health of
this place and like there's so much
harry potter going on right am i
the only one seeing i would hope so
dumbledore and harry like a little bit
and like when harry just walks into the
great hall he's like why is it snowing
and they're like oh because dumbledore's
sad or you know there's like something
else
there's always some kind of like a
broader mystical reason why and it's
just usually it can be explained quickly
with a joke and then we move on like
dumbledore ran out of episodes of a
queer eye and he's pretty upset because
he feels great yeah and this is doctor
mt i think you got closest to the right
answer i'm giving you the point there
hooray
i can't wait to figure out it was just a
door that exploded and i was right
thermostat is broken and the repairman
won't come for another two thousand yeah
yeah yeah yeah exactly
well uh before we move on to road
questions we want to thank bluetooth for
sponsoring this episode uh our friends
at blue chew have a unique online
service that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis but in
a chewable form and at a fraction of the
cost
speaking of midlife crises bluechoo is
an online prescription service so no
doctor's office or pharmacy trips it
ships right to your door in a discreet
package you sign up at bluetooth.com
consult with one of their licensed
medical providers and once you're
approved you receive your prescription
within days their licensed medical
providers work with you to find the
right ingredient in strength and if you
hate swallowing pills good news blue
chew is chewable just like it says in
the name so if you could benefit from
some extra confidence when it's time to
perform visit bluetooth.com for more
details and important safety information
and we've got a special deal for our
audience try bluetooth for free when you
use our promo code rogue at checkout
just pay the five dollars in shipping
that's bluechew.com promo code rogue to
receive your first month free and thanks
again to bluetooth for sponsoring this
episode all right guys back
to rogue
questions we got some other big news
this week of uh cinemacon that's where
the spider-man no way home trailer
initially premiered uh we also got news
about like the matrix four matrix uh
resurrections and then uh the batman
apparently there's footage shown of that
or just news coming out about the batman
uh the robert pattinson one uh from
director matt reeves and uh wait for it
matt reeves said quote that his version
of batman could be the most emotional
batman movie ever made so i want you
guys to pitch me your theories on how
the robert pattinson batman will be the
most emotional batman and this is this
is funny because this is the first like
our final rogue question thing that's
not just comedy inspired it's like right
this is the darkest one possible but you
can make it funny what do you want make
it funny
this going to be the this is going to be
the batman movie where like they just
take it over the top with bruce brooding
over his parents so every scene is going
to be like my parents are dead okay like
he's fighting his batman he's just
crying he's like i'm doing this for you
dad
i'm just crying every scene it's like
yes an emotional batman we want to see
the side of bruce i kind of do want to
see that i think jesus is
saying i'm doing this for thomas he is a
mentally disturbed person at the end of
the day batman needs therapy so like it
would make sense for an over emotional
batman just beat up everyone in gotham
with tears in his eyes makes sense to me
i will be his therapist um specifically
only robert pattinson's batman but i
think i think uh kind of going off of
mt's lines this batman that we're seeing
is a batman that's not really
old enough to like know better but also
trying to do better so when we saw that
scene a long time ago of him just
beating the hell out of someone and he
just kept going it was so like energized
and charged with just like anger and he
didn't know how to place it and that's
why this batman
kind of mirroring today is just like
he's not a hero it's like he's not a
hero we don't know what to think of him
because he's just beating people on the
street when he's like also a villain
deep down not a villain but he's just a
bad guy deep down it's like
who are you to say who's the bad guy
you're following these orders from
people given that are also bad so who
are you so i think that's why it's going
to be darker and more emotionally driven
is because it's mirroring not only like
what's going on in the world but just
he's just a sad boy that doesn't know
what he's doing correctly yeah he's a
sad boy i love that yeah and i think
just
we're all picking back on piggybacking
on all of that like i feel like
it's gonna dig deeper into just that
psyche that that
that mental status of being
angsty without having a proper outlet i
feel like matt reeves is is going to
take the opportunity to address all
those things that we obviously know
obviously batman is psychologically you
know on off the level and needs that
kind of help so i think
i think matt reeves is going to use this
film pretty much to establish that that
is the foundation
of the the world's greatest detective in
that emotionally he's still that little
boy who is with his dead parents in an
alleyway even in the form of a grown
adult person or a young adult and i feel
like through this film there's going to
be a lot of laws that are just going to
add on to that pile that he's already
feeling and so emotionally
we we get the the amazing um
opportunities to see
that being exposed in the rawness of
that emotion because once he's grown
once he's older he knows how to mask a
lot of that he knows how to keep it from
just pretty much every single person
that's important to him or can or they
consider him important to him
and this is going to be an opportunity
where it's just going to be a raw
emotional opportunity uh where you see
that constantly in every instance not
only in fighting but in just one-on-one
silent moments see i think that's a very
good answer i think you guys are right
that's probably what matt reaves by it
being an emotional movie but here's what
i think
i think what's gonna happen is
uh we're gonna follow robert pattinson
bruce wayne and in the final scene in
the movie he's gonna be uh at his father
thomas's office uh in a in a high rise
oh my gosh the camera is going to pull
out and it's going to be the north tower
of the world trade center and then
it's going to be september 11 2001 and
it's going to be the same movie as that
awful remember me rum that
[Music]
i thought you were going to make like a
planet of the apes references
and instead i sprinted into it ran past
the finish line and all the way
down
i really hope it's the pain i asked for
an emotional
emotional batman movie so does that mean
we're getting pierce brosnan as thomas
wayne
yes
oh yeah i think it works
it works for me
ah
[Music]
true anyway no we're going we're moving
on
jessica for having the proper emotional
response to my awful pitch gets two
points if you win this episode of rogue
theory it was a test i willy walker
i tested you guys and only jessica
succeeded i hate this so much
i i was very much like 9 11. maybe let's
not do that
oh god i don't know
i'm not seriously pitching 911
you guys don't know comedy like i
if i can't make jokes about that anymore
why are we conto yeah this white male
comedy i've always hated it
[Laughter]
well jessica you win
everyone wins not me though i lose
but that's okay
we're all winners that's it for this
episode of rogue theory i want to thank
our guest jessica clements eddie
villanueva and mt follow all three of
them on social media uh support them in
all of their endeavors you could support
this channel by checking out our new
limited edition no way home shirt and
this what if shirt at new rockstars
newrockstarsmerch.com
follow me at eavos follow new rockstars
subscribe to rockstars here on youtube
and we will see you next time
bye
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign